I want to thought that today this
afternoon we'd be talking about
the mysterious problems
this right the I thought what why do you
think it's like not even on the table
and you find the problem well the
problem of qualia the problem of
subjective experience the the what it's
like to be a fat problem the things of
course the dam has spent a lot of time
fighting against for a long time and
when which we all appreciate that it
sounded good no but it obviously it it's
like whack-a-mole
you know we've got you know nebula again
giving us this crap and it's being taken
seriously all over the place right yeah
you probably gotta say get the story
quickly well it's the idea that there
are it that there is an what it's like
to be conscious that is incapable of
being captured by third person
neuroscience that there is a an
aboutness of human thought that is
incapable of being realized by
input/output neurological systems and
which provides to the mysterion's the
strongest basis for their rejection of
materialism and naturalism or simply to
say that science could never touch it
yes okay that's interesting why because
I actually [ __ ] work through them we
were
at some point there and my taken Nagle's
paper which I reread it recently because
one of my classes I mean what it's like
there what is like yeah I know he's
honest takes I mean we should yeah I
think we should bracket that the new
book out because it is it sound I
haven't read it I've read only two or
three reviews of it and it sounds really
but the so I want to hear what people
think about that what is it like to be a
bad thing I I took that the message of
that I know I'm not saying that this
isn't one Nagel intended but I took that
to say not that the strong implication
that is that there's no there's
something somehow on that science cannot
touch or cannot explain or whatever it
is about conscious experience is calling
all at but simply that if we want to
apply the third-person scientific
analysis to first-person experiences
we're making a category mistake you know
no matter what your how well are good
your description inaccurate your
description is of the way the human
brain works you're not gonna have that
experience unless you are that brain so
we're not never gonna have this
appearance of being a bad that doesn't
mean we cannot understand how bad work
is that not sensible well that's not
what I'm saying but it's that not more
sensible one problem is frustrating a
lot of people think that that's a paper
that argues that we cannot know what
it's like to be a battery if you look
closely you realize he never argues for
that he assumes that we can never know
what it's like to be a bad inany argues
about what the implications of his
premise for and and that's a huge bit of
misdirection right there but then
there's a there is a fundamental
ambiguity in his paper which I think I
finally got to the bottom of there's two
senses in which you could be making the
assumption that we
imagine what it's like to be a bet one
is we just lack the the pigments on our
palette to imagine it because bats are
so different from us and the other is oh
we whether or not we could imagine it we
could never confirm that we've done it
successfully to come compare we could
never imagine what the winning lottery
number in the tomorrow is well yeah you
could by accident you just wouldn't know
if you were right till the next day so
there's a question of whether it's
confirming imagination or whether it's
just not being able to render an
imagination what it's like to be about I
think a lot of people think because he's
talking about bats that he means the
first because they don't have
echolocation because you know so forth
we don't have the pigments in our
palette we just hit it but in fact
that's not what he means or at least
it's not
Bandon said because I must put it to a
point-blank on justice by said suppose
you had a twin brother who was also a
philosopher could you imagine what it's
like to be him if it's pigments he
should say yeah of course he said no
then what the heck is he talking about
bats for notice notice that there is
some something like sleight of hand
going on why does he bother stressing
how alien bats are from us if if he
could just as well be talking about an
identical twin brother with him and of
course there's there's another conflict
in that paper and that is he goes on and
on about that
why because presumably is telling us
something about what it's like to be a
vacuum and why wouldn't more of the same
tell us more and more about what it's
like Richard of course if you were here
would time in that how furious he is it
nickel because what Nagel took and put
in that paper was developed by a
well-known british that scientist during
world war two well happiness and i had
to depend upon what it's like to be the
back huh you know yes you can do it
it means the very premise of his of his
papers is wrong why guys for those of
you who were not following us on twitter
somebody just treated the following in
honor of move naturalism here are some
bat embryos and what is it like to be a
bat by thundaga andres there so there's
a picture of three bat embryos that
these guys posted I think there are
discussions
you